talk to me about how you reflect on your
relationship with Kai Greene because
people yeah the greatest rivalry in
bodybuilding and it's then the stakes
are raised with generation again is the
Inception of social media right talk to
me about that relationship with Kai
Greene I think it's
I think it is the greatest rivalry I
think it's bigger than Jay and Ronnie's
just because they were friends we
weren't and I think we wanted to be
friends Kai and I but I feel like
because of we want us both wanting
something so freaking bad and during the
social media era one camp
the other camp they're talking so much
and we can see the chatter
that it kind of made it look like so you
don't like me Chris okay uh it's like
high school you know I mean like you
talking [__] and then all you do is look
at me weird and I'm like all right
what's up so
I know that Kai had to play
psychological warfare because this is
bodybuilding it's not MMA it's not
boxing you know like it's not even
basketball or football right
it's just
a person lifting weights and dieting and
doing heavy amounts of cardio imposing
that is hard to impose your will on
someone physically
so you got to figure out how he can beat
me so for him to start a fight you know
like in 2014 flipping the hair and all
this other stuff I don't blame him
people used to get mad at me for like
accepting it like in my like friends
circle they're like man like you're just
cool but I said I expected it they're
like how did you why did you expect this
I said listen it all started at the damn
press conference
but I knew he was going to do something
I didn't know what I was going to
respond by saying the three facts and
all this other stuff he'd signed his
name oh yeah Mr Olympia yeah he started
doing your like over your face or
something yeah yeah yeah so we have a we
have an Olympia poster that comes out
every year so when we get our Olympia
credentials you know our per diem all
that good stuff we have to sign a bunch
of merchandise one of it is like a big
ass poster that we give all the VIP
holders so you know of course you know
I'm like it's front and center so people
are going to sign like maybe the leg or
this and that this fool like on the face
I'm like oh it's like that Annie wrote
Mr Olympia I'm like
okay
how many times did he do it for like a
whole row of them I'm like oh he's
trying to send a message
so uh you know basketball mentality
comes out right now it's like oh this is
ah I love it the disrespect I love it
like now I get to
make this more intentional
and he has no idea what I look like
he's then going to try to probably say
something at this press conference why
because that's what I would do
know thyself know your opponent
know how to respond versus react see
when you don't play through these things
I mean you only get fixated on how much
food and water do I drink and yes I have
to do this mundane stuff you need to
work on the mind of figuring out all the
different permutations that can exist
all the different scenarios that can
happen
that way you know how to handle yourself
in anything that comes towards you so
I get I gave him what he needed at the
press conference and he had nothing to
say after that and that's when I knew
the only thing left was for him to try
to do something physical and I handled
it well and
unfortunately that was like the end of
that prejudging yeah they split you
apart right yeah Dennis wolf in between
you and yeah no one's walking through
him I mean in a way it was it was it was
effed up because I'm like
we're not performing now
um and it was a big adrenaline dump as
well for he and I both I know he
probably had it because sister talk to
me you're on stage you've worked toward
this thing for ages Generation Iron is
out yeah it's already out for the second
year yeah so you've got the Rivalry is
not only private it's public yep you've
had him signing his name on your face
literally
on posters you've had him talking [__]
at the press conference yep and then you
get on stage and he's got this like
Predator ponytail thing he whips and
hits you with and then has something to
say and then you sort of jostle against
each other and then there's this
legendary photo of you finally turning
and looking and it's you guys face to
face on the Olympic stage
what's that
emotional dump like with all of this
pressure and all of this preparation
coming up it's it felt like high school
when everybody's like fight fight fight
fight and then
you're basically getting into it and
then there and then there was the fans
energy that I felt that got calm because
all you could hear is
if you if you if you were there you
would be able to hear Steve weinberger's
voice get elevated and they turn the
music up louder because they wanted I
guess they were trying to drown out the
crowd noise like like it was cheering it
on because they kind of were
and then I realized
two big ass dudes oiled up in posing
trunks you're supposed to fight
nah you're not paying enough for this
nah exactly someone's getting their
drawers pulled out you know hey it ain't
happening that's not the fight that I
signed up for so uh let's go ahead and
calm this [__] down and get back to work
but you're right so
I realize right then and there the fans
really messed this up
because the fans were egging us on for
two two years now
because you got to think
uh 2012 there was a moment where Kai and
I are posing you know you do the back
shots and I used to always kind of like
that was in 2013. so 2012. we're doing a
back shot
and I look back no I look like this and
I'm kind of like looking at the glutes
because it's kind of like letting the
judges know he ain't got what I got
so I was like come on man oh you slapped
him on the ass I I kind of like touched
like touch his lower back or something
like that should have slapped him on the
ass and then uh so then he was he
there's a picture of him like looking he
was gonna punch me yes yes so no one
remembers this right but but you know
what it did that was the no Flinch with
Matt Barnes versus Kobe
so I was like yes I got him yep now I'm
in his head
he wants to like you know all right 2013
Arnold Classic uh Madrid
that's when we're doing this
and he's just pissed and I'm like got
him how do you think so it seems like
your ability to deal with discomfort
both
psychological physical
it's balanced I I think discomfort in
the time but it doesn't seem to Echo you
don't seem to ruminate beyond what you
need to to learn the lessons right
what do you know about how Kai felt
during this rivalry well he had to feel
I mean of course he's going to feel
robbed right because he's going to think
well
I look good too I put in so much effort
I've gone through so many levels so many
levels of adversity I deserve this
and I'm only one person away
one person away and then once I got him
out of my way I can have everything I've
ever wanted
I get to now every time I see Phil Heath
I see success I see what life is
presented him and what he's been able to
experience and I can't have the same
thing without going through him I got to
go through him
so there's a level of empathy I have
even now like I I realized I've spoken
to him yeah we've you know it's very
interesting is that we've had a few
conversations Kai Greene gets credit for
me because he was the first athlete in
the ifbb to call me after I lost in
2018.
and he was the only one
he was the only one that picked up the
phone and we talked at length
and that made me feel I mean
it wasn't like an emotional like like
I'm gonna cry it was more like
the person who knows me the most is the
one that I battled against the most
right
and he basically gave me some some much
needed words of like Phil they didn't
beat
Phil that I know they beat an injured
one
you're still
the best ever and to hear that
you know it it made me feel good because
well in my opinion he was right
and he would he would know that because
he was he knew what he was going against
and he knows that
man if if
imagine the amount of stress Phil had to
go through and I need to I need to reach
out to him and let him know like
everything's cool man you're gonna be
okay like and he's already he was mind
you 2018 I mean he was already four
years or three years removed because
either the Arnold Australia I believe in
um so he had already started that
transition away yeah and I had yet to
decide if that was what I wanted to do
so he was giving me an option on that
phone call of saying Phil now you're at
this point where
you don't have to prove yourself to
anyone
um
the judges can do whatever the hell they
want
you've solidified yourself
like I respect you and I thought damn
like
thank you and you know since then I mean
we've always had that you know casual I
mean now granted during the conversation
there was still Fu Phil and this and the
other you know just because we can't
it's like
we can't be like Hallmark cards and
roses and [__] we still got to be like I
respect you but [__] you man you know
what I mean like and I'm cool with it I
saw Kai last year at the gym shark event
here in California and we both were just
like there's just that Vibe and we both
know that it's cool it's cool to be like
him saying [__] you Phil Heathen I said
[__] you Kai you know what I mean like
it's all and you know it's funny it's
sweet yeah it's like a term of
endearment and fans though like when
they see us in the room like everyone
would get quiet oh they think they're
still yeah and there isn't there's more
respect than anything because
that's what it should be but it always
was it's just that when you're battling
we respected the game when when I don't
think people have seen
I mean outside of a a j and Ronnie
situation two highly competitive people
that were boisterous about what they
wanted we were extremely voicerous and
if that meant that we ruffled the
feathers of the opposite team we didn't
give a [__]
we just didn't we couldn't because we
needed their support we needed those
fans sometimes to remind us like yeah
man like okay we got this I mean I would
see people arguing at the Olympia Expo
over who's going to win and this that
Kai's fans coming up talking trash and
I'm like
remember posing in the audience and
people would you know say stuff and I'm
like
what happened to your boy you know and
then the fans like Oh and it was like
the so it was like some WWE uh stuff
correct and as much as some fans want to
make it seem like for me I was being
like extremely like negative or whatever
I was playing along just like them
because at the same time I mean we're
providing Sports entertainment
and if I can have a little fun with a
troll online I'm gonna do it you know
like and and uh because I should have
fun I should have fun with this this is
great like it's really cool that I can
have certain types of powers that I can
literally transform my physique into
something that no one that could ever
imagine well think about it this way as
well that it's not just
the enjoyment of being the Sportsman but
it's the enjoyment of being
a personality as well of you know
developing a brand and if the brand for
a short amount of time is to be the
villain like no one no one looks back
Floyd Mayweather you know like played
for a very long time they did a
he fought
on Cinco de Mayo and called it Cinco de
Mayweather yeah and came out with the
sombrero yep yeah and just a
professional troll before the word troll
exists that's right right do it and now
looking back people I mean some of his
most recent fights maybe his padded his
right record a little bit but uh I think
that playing that heel and doing that is
I don't know if you have the psychology
to be able to absorb it yeah and stay
equanimous yeah I think that
that makes for a much more exciting it
the greatest rivalry in bodybuilding
right it wouldn't have existed had you
not have had the Rivalry yeah right it's
not it wasn't because of the bodies
maybe it was in some regards
but it was because of the personalities
yeah that was what made it happen and it
drove
competitiveness
how much better do you think you became
because of Kai Greene oh extremely I
mean every year it was like
you get to see him guest pose on the
circuit and you're like oh [__] did you
respect his his physique oh of course I
I knew
I respected it all the time the problem
is is that just because I respect it and
I have an opinion of it
like parts of me was like gosh all they
had to do
was be who he was when he did those
Arnold Classics and the 2012 Olympia and
he might have got me
maybe that's the difference because he
got bigger and he was trying to imagine
uh manage too much size Kai green is
probably probably if not the most dense
bodybuilder we have ever seen
that includes Coleman like density wise
because you got to think you're shorter
than Coleman weighed as much nearly as
much
and it was like deep separate deep Cuts
Like deep deep like very like slabs of
beef like when he does the pulling the
elbows back and you see the Christmas
tree thick let's try it in lats
um just very deep now he lacked the
chest size and the depth with that and
the shoulder so that's why Coleman would
get the edge but you know people think
of Dorian Ace like being very dense
if we could see those two up on stage
together I'm telling you right now Kai
Greene like because of the quads because
of the side of the hamstring the hanging
of the
forget it it was just slabs of beef dude
like this guy you've seen him walk
around off season and and every 3x pants
that he's wearing looks like they're
leggings I mean it's just it's
amazing and he was able to keep this
condition throughout the entire
bodybuilding season so I I would always
look at him and say well
you're you're not focusing on one major
thing and that is the peak
and bodybuilding is about the peaking
you can run the 100 meters in the
semifinals and break the world record
but wouldn't you rather do an Olympic
final I'd rather do an Olympic final
it's more significant then and it takes
more discipline it takes more strategy
so that's where I I looked at
bodybuilding it's like everything is a
strategy everything is a process leaning
up to two days that's it all you got to
do is be ready for two days
and that you know I was able to do that
obviously countless times but yeah uh
did he raise my game level up absolutely
and I and I benefit from it in other
news this episode is brought to you by
element element is a tasty electrolyte
drink mix with everything that you need
and nothing that you don't it's a
healthy alternative to sugary
electrolyte drinks and it is the best
way that I've started my morning every
single day for over three years now it
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
with no sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients or any other junk your
adenosine system the caffeine acts on
isn't active for the first 90 minutes of
the day but your adrenal system is and
salt acts on your adrenal system so if
you want to be more awake you want to
regulate your appetite curb cravings and
have better brain health this is the way
to start your day head to drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom to get a free sample pack
of all eight flavors with your first box
plus there is a no BS no questions asked
refund policy so you can buy it 100 risk
free that's drinklmnt.com
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Phil then press here for the full length
two hour podcast episode when we go so
deep in the history of his career his
Reflections on Generation Iron the Peds
that he did and did not use plus his 10
best exercises for men to build muscle
[Music]